et pour en parler nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec claude blanche maison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison boris
johnson à qui s'est défendu une nouvelle
fois mékong là mais on sent que les
sauts l'étau se resserre autour de lui
je crois qu'il est dans l'oeil du
cyclone aujourd'hui bord et jeunes seul
et il assure l'ancien conseiller
politique que mym qui répètent partout
que il a d'autres affaires dansant dans
son sac et que d'autres affaires
pourrait pourrait sortir
il y à l enquête administrative qui est
conduite par la numéro deux de
l'administration du premier ministre qui
devrait trouver des résultats très
bientôt peut-être existe-t-il déjà parce
qu'il ya une nouveauté depuis hier c'est
que la police du grand londres s'est
saisi du dossier et que sa directrice
est intervenu en disant qu'elle avait
des éléments qui faisaient que en effet
une enquête devait être ouverte et
probablement elle a eu accès aux
premières conclusions de l'enquêté
administrative donc boris johnson en
effet est en difficulté mais avec une
enquête de police il a gagné un délai
parce que 54 des polices elle va prendre
quelques semaines et donc il ne sera pas
ce mai par les chefs de son parti de
démissionner pendant ces quelques
semaines alors le leader de libourne a
accusé de mépriser le pays et le
président de la chambre des communes a
dû intervenir à plusieurs reprises pour
maintenir le calme réprimant d'ailleurs
au passage un député travailliste qui
avait qualifié boris johnson de menteur
est ce qu'on a à faire une crise
politique au royaume uni donc le leader
de l'opposition il fait son travail
c'est à dire qu'ils critiquent le
gouvernement est dans le système
britannique c'est tout à fait légitime
et logique alors évidemment par ailleurs
il ya des députés conservateurs qui ne
sont pas contents et qu'ils le
manifestent ya probablement un début de
révolte notamment chez les plus jeunes
mais je crois que pour le moment boris
johnson arrive aller à les contenir
alors y aura
également d'autres moyens peut-être de
sauver sa peau c'est vous l'avais dit
dans l'autre jour la fin des
restrictions liées au co vide qui somme
toute est assez populaire l'envoi par
exemple de militaires dans la manche
pour repousser les migrants ça suffira
redorer le blason du premier ministre en
clair est-ce qu'il va réussir à sauver
sa place c'est important en effet pour
les élus conservateurs aux communes
puisque ce sont des libéraux qui veulent
dans les faits qui est le moins de 2 que
de contraintes possibles venant le
gouvernement sur les citoyens et c'est
un peu le sens des mesures qui ont été
décidées en effet il ya une semaine
alors par ailleurs la marine pour
contenir les arrivées de migrants par la
manche ça c'est une idée déjà ancien je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit très efficace
parce que la marine britannique a
l'habitude d'appliquer le droit
international et le droit international
c'est que lorsque les gens sont en train
de se noyer il faut laisser courir donc
reste à voir ce que fera la marine de sa
majesté britannique
autre sujet évidemment on l'a vu dans
votre votre sujet précédent la situation
internationale est très tendue mais
boris johnson salines qui sema tiquement
sur sur joe biden et par conséquent il
n'est pas sûr que ce soit le meilleur
moment pour changer le premier ministre
et pour avoir
une sorte de changements qu'on peut être
complète gouvernement parce que les
candidats à sa succession sont mises
affaires étrangères émis des finances
donc il est probable que la crise
internationale que nous vivons pas aussi
donné un ballon d'oxygène à boris
johnson alors il n'y a pas même 40% des
électeurs conservateurs qui souhaitent
sa démission 1 qu'en est il vraiment des
britanniques est ce qu'ils vont suivre
effectivement s'il ya 40% des électeurs
conservateurs qui sont pour sa démission
ça fait environ 70 % de l'ensemble des
électeurs britanniques puisque par
définition les travaillistes ont contre
lui mais si on regarde ce qui compte
aujourd'hui pour ceux éventuellement
vote de censure c'est les conservateurs
aurillac 15 % des députés conservateurs
qui a moins de 15 % arrêtés qui sont
contre lui car s'il y en avait 15 % il y
aurait 50 quatre signatures qu'ils
demanderaient
au leadership des parties d'entamer la
procédure de défiance et ça n'est pas le
cas et en effet boris johnson s'emploie
à ce que ce ne soit pas le cas merci
beaucoup claude blanchou maison nous
avoir apporté ce décryptage et on verra
un petit peu voilà les derniers
développements dans les prochaines
semaines concernant boris johnson
mercier beau